the hello photos welcome to
today's reign aline tiemi increasing the efficiency
of the molecular diagnostics laboratory
my name is luciana gentil manager of
scientific affairs in the water go to the
governor presents today
today's educational webinar is presented
by hand and brought  to you from
the americas scientific affairs team from
the molecular division of water before we
begin I would like to remind everyone that
this event is imperative we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you like at any time
during the presentation to do so
just type them in the box a  often and
click without we will answer bills second
if we have time at the end of the
presentation if you have it raining
to see listen to the presentation click on
the support tab located in the
upper right corner of the
presentation window or report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located at the end  left of the
screen can now present
jorge bar  bosa josé duarte himself he is a
researcher at the institute of
tropical medicine at the university of são paulo and is
currently head of the molecular biology unit at
water laboratories to
obtain a complete biography about our
speaker visit the biography tab at
the top of the screen step now the
word opens the  santander eduardo
lei thank you very much luciana too production
is a pleasure for me i'm here with you
to talk about the aline tiemi system the
first equipment of this type in
south america was actually
installed in the americas it was placed in the
dasa laboratory and we didn't make a series  of
experience with the equipment there is what
I'm going to tell you now below
I want to thank you for the invitation to say that
this program is known as the support
program by abglt a luciana has already
said this is my account bible
biography right i'm a biologist with a master's degree
at the university of são paulo in
molecular biology of the doctorate in biology
also at the university of são p  aulo and
since 1995 i've been a researcher
at usp's institute of tropical medicine and
i've been in the given laboratory since 2016
for four years and a little bit that i'm
waking up to pass tell me you
molecular first and more recently
this function of research and
development network  from the pot of
healthy clinical analysis so it's like aline
was also part of a research project, it
went through the collection and all the
cream in your hand from any
research project as we do here in
brazil was coordinated and conducted there
by my department and  that's why I'm
here today to present
our experience to you agenda quickly will
eat three aspects is the
operational needs of our
molecular biology laboratory what makes sense
equipment like this like alinity
evaluation of the performance of the tests we
did there and lastly  and step there and
operational awareness designed in the
high-volume lab
is it true and what are the implications
for  the possible implications to be able to offer
this type of service our doctors
more aware of our supported laboratories
I am quickly presenting the date
for you for those who do not know the dasa
is given the acronym of diagnostics of
america is in the name inside that what
a turn to result  da is
nowadays we only use da asa it is the
largest diagnostic medicine company in
latin america the fifth largest in the world
today we profess 250
million exams every year when we want
clinical analysis and we also have the
imaging part  where we do around eight
million imaging exams per year
our activities are divided into these
four sectors right 75 percent of
the company's revenue is derived from what
we have and private are the different
flags of da so there is no
laboratory called data  actually
people always keep the name of the
laboratories that are being acquired right
then because here in são
paulo my de  u bolo and the author from rio de
janeiro sérgio franco bronze pai lámina
and so on brasilia the exam there
is there in goiânia santa luzia in
florianópolis there are several others there are 37
laboratories today make this network that
we are private and which accounts for
75  Percent of billing then
we have the support laboratory and the
Álvaro brand where we support more than
4,500 laboratories throughout Brazil
we are inside more than 100 hospitals
where we use the same
private flags inside the hospitals and we have a
laboratory  scientific side that
amounts to the public sector will account for
five percent of the billing
molecular biology activity and
hell's we're going to paste here it is
concentrated mainly in são paulo
and such a large laboratory of
molecular biology is in são paulo we have
a laboratory  a little smaller in rio de
janeiro and then outside são paulo and rio
de janeiro we only work with some
other system it is small of
Molecular biology is within the
hospital operation nuclei, so what I
'm going to talk about basically refers to a
desire to have a clear week in são
paulo the biggest one this laboratory operates
24 hours a day seven days a week
we count here in são paulo  paulo with 55
collaborators including pharmaceutical biomedical biologists
some with postgraduate degrees
with a master's or doctorate
the and on average people go 2019 performed 52
thousand molecular tests per month these
tests and divide as follows this
will be important for later we
discuss the limit  so here
you can see so I selected here are
the other exams but we have an
average of over a thousand tests per month it is given
in the coast of são paulo
operational technical center of são paulo let's
see come here blue that mainly
we  prepared which our best we do
molecular research is the
human papillomavirus hpv almost 10 thousand tests per month
already hpv sometimes using more than one  the
platform here I'm focusing on the
people or something of the test and then
because a mile is the second in third
place hiv viral load that is in gray
and in four places it is already a test that
is not infectious that the determination of the
fetal sex also a molecular test we
do here in são paulo and then
there are all these others we
will not keep reading but I just wanted to
show here that we have a mixture and
mainly infectious and something
of tests that will be cataloged as
genetics so the factor 5 there and for
example or hb27 prothrombin polymorphism
are genetic tests but they are
also done in the molecular biology laboratory
now to call attention that the
two most important species in terms
of volume chlamydia and hpv are tests
related to  women's gynecological health
and especially men's health, but
especially women's health, so they
are very important people for us to
spend an important week after  is the
acquisition where you from salomão and
zoppi the laboratory is very
well known and totally focused on
women's health well already entering so it's in
a study that you did we in
this sector of molecular biology we
have platforms equipment and
systems from different companies  but
abot is our main partner, that
is molecular and we use
the system a lot in the dm-2000 system
they are already known systems and that have been on the market for a long time, it
is worldwide and in Brazil
and we can see the picture on the side here
left so the semi 2000 system they
can be explained as it is comprising
two units a first unit
where we put a primary sample or an
aliquot in our primary and it is then
extracted and it is set up in the
real time PCR setup that goes  be
carried out after the 96 plate, the
95% elcio is then manually loaded from here
to the other space although here in the handle
it is all together where we
and the anal  the effects in
real time and in our case it has a
direct interface with our liquor
laboratory system the results after an
analysis by the operator are migrated
directly to the single laboratory and
from there to the system for releasing the
result is this type of system  the
system in which the logic of betes follows is
to group samples from 92 to 94 to
death according to the number of controls that
are used and more controls
i.e. the 96 plate and a 96 plate of the
average takes about  6 to 7 hours to
release the results is
breast equipment is daily maintenance
hi and preparing some preparation to see
us although most of us are
almost ready but they still need
some preparation then they are placed
completely overnight at each race  and on the
right side we can see here the
equipment that we are going to discuss the ali
elite nm sells molecular and it is already a
system it is fully integrated you are the
only equipment there is no other
equipment  The equipment associated with the samples can
be randomly placed, which
is very important and what makes
the seller's great difference in relation not
only to the system that preceded the M2000 but
in relation to other molecular systems
available on the market is the question of
random access for sure  samples do not
need to wait for other samples that are
going to be tested for the same target to
be placed in the equipment, they are simply
placed as a form you have not
received,
which allows a much more
dynamic and much more flexible
laboratory logic in relation to another way of
working in the system  standing up he
needs to run a control every
48 hours or positive control
negative control that is how he is fed
in a walk mika way you will never have
a control for that group of
samples but it is a control that will be
passed every 24  or 48 hours in which
you will run that particular routine
the first 12 results come out two
hours later  equipment allows you to
load 12 hacks from 12 to the bike, it is not
the first load with 144
samples the first result will come out
in two hours after loading and
then I will come out with 12 more results
every sixteen minutes I equipment
that requires much less maintenance and owns
it there is a  process takes a
while and a monthly maintenance process
no longer exists in daily maintenance and there
is no kind of preparation that we
have everything ready and it is placed and the
bot stays inside the equipment for a
stipulated time that it has the  its
duration according to the type of
people you want placed there and of course
the equipment he always calculates and the
doctor he has a day that we are
able to perform that number of tests
for which it is only then being the
samples otherwise it will warn the
operator that it needs to be loaded
and our exams so this study that
was not called funk on everything of
familiarization with the
lab equipment  oratorio with equipment and we
then used the final tests that
were used in this evaluation all
the tests for which there are
availability is already commercially available
for alinity which are
hiv viral load viral load
hepatitis b viral load sexually
transmitted infections and  the high-risk hpv test
and what we analyzed in
relation to these tests we did not finalize the
accuracy, reproducibility and
sensitivity using panels and it is
characterized that they were provided by
the water company itself and then we
need to study the correlation of
methods there with samples  rounds then in the
system is chosen by the laboratory in
the bad case it starts with the m2000 itself and
then the tabocas itself repeated in the air
the video of the correlation between the two
hi boxes and then a more operational analysis
in which the response time was analyzed
you already  counted the time each of the
equipment took to process the
same number of samples to per  allow
us to work out what would be the gain or
what will be the gain by introducing a
threshold system in our laboratory
well so let's start with alite hiv
a viral load test is to
analyze this one we are talking to
this panel as I commented with you
go there  that was known cleaning boot
this panel comprises
plasma samples of patience and has and containing so
front subtypes of front to hiv-1
subtype b summit you and your corrective
combining form circulating recombinant form
is a g is a quite a
quite frequent recombinant in
africa united states is a little
less in brazil as well and these
three made samples so at four
concentration levels a thousand copies per ml 200
glasses premiere 50 glasses per ml 20 copies
per ml so
what about each of them or tested three
aliquots then  we arrive at the 180
amps that I mentioned to you that
we did 36 cities a day so these
were tested on 5 different days
quot your results so we see here on
this first slide the result of that one
we are analyzing the accuracy of there is
limit so touch here the moto subtypes
and the dead ash of the ag15 sample of type
b with the level of one thousand copies per ml and
what  we checked it was a
very small standard deviation 0300700 12
according to the subtype that gives a body
feel variation around two to
four percent which is a
very acceptable variation coefficient when
we for you the second prepare the
second the preparation one  200 copies per
ml we see that the coefficient of variation
increases a little bit as expected, the
closer to the reception limit the
greater the variation but even
so, even though the variation postulated by this equipment is very low,
the variation does not exceed 0.5
log10 basel.  here
we are oscillating between 01010101 of
course this is there blog baseeia
is also
o and here we have the third third
dilution point 50 copies per ml
we see that something that you have
a slightly higher evaluation too but
never reaches the value of 0.5
percent, it's still between six to fourteen
percent of coefficient of variation
and what is important in relation to the
coefficient of variation and it  is not
greater than what is used to
value one from a clinical point of view
so and hiv and general and they value
higher viral load changes in half love
basel so as a coefficient of
variation it is always less than 0
25 means that it will not  there is a
clinical decision making due to a
variation in the result of the equipment
because this variation rate is lower
than what you value from the point of view
of clinical response 11 clinical response
based on viral load from the point of view
is qualitative that we have the  even from
the easiest point of dilution in the 20
copies per
ml what all times of subtypes b and
subtypes and all that should
present the detectable result that
central and  without considering the
quantifiable value for one detected and one of
the subjective replicas we were not
detected giving a general
detection rate of 97.7 the center a and here
we go reproducibility of the
controls the controls already have
concentrations a concentration apart
from the day  it's 100,000 copies per ml and another
in the range of any heart of a thousand
copies per ml will be strong
positive or weak positive 12 replicates and what the
agent there the average of the logo of copies per
ml so very close to what's on the
leaflet how how  the value and the standard deviation are
very low here in relation to the
and the replicas of the songs of the controls
that were run so for the
viral load already limit it is important for us to
put here that this result of the
infection rate is important it is important
because it is often used  the
viral load test for qualitative diagnosis,
this is accepted by the Brazilian press,
including the whole world, it is used
this way, right, so the patient has
to do it  an antibody already said already
positive hiv with a viral load
regardless of the positive value it is
considered then a confirmation
of hiv detection that it is important that
this very low limit that I took
this new version of the anime if it is more
sensitive than the disease  2008
just follow that it has a high detection rate like
that in the sample and we know
that in Brazil the most frequent
subtype is subtype b and the
15 percent of infections in the country
continue to be when you type b
we have the and also  but present in the
south of the country go
ah so that's how we
concluded the analytical evaluation of the
hiv test hiv viral load through
the panels and we left for the
correlation study correlation study study
more of the real world in the sense of  which are
part of the routine of the laboratory and which
were so tested the primary tube itself
was tested in the year 2000 and then
within 30 days the hand was kept
frozen and then thought  das in
the alinity system so all these bikes
like i said i'm not a little primary
collected in everything like pt of course our
running everything and with a wide range of
results from 90 hectares to the show
that the cardinal brings low medium and high
concern and represent  well the whole
spectrum of expected results
freddy's 3 hair analysis being
us hiv
the hpv video
and here we see then this correlation
between what was run in the routine on
the m2188 platform the hiv bike tested by
hiv 12 thousand and the result of the  aline
so we see that the general agreement
counts ninety-two percent which is
quite high we had only 15 and
discrepancy 12 of these discrepancies
they were a coded value in
alinity it was not considered as not
detected the name 2000 previously
although i  I have been told that
the threshold sensitivity is lower so by all
people would expect these samples to
be the viral load just in them preset
not fluency or va  So, of course,
aline showed the values ​​that in theory
would be detectable by the m2000 plus an
oven, so we have two here
important samples later
and
then what was coded within this
range here of one of the six or seven
logo and copies in the m2000 masculinity
it accused and detected it still on the bike I'm
inside its detection limit which gives
one of the three more cups which is the value of
21 shows that it was simply not
detected by the by the limit so it was
this very good relationship we
found it and we went ahead with the analysis
this one in relation to the sample per sample
which is a correlation coefficient
because this global relationship, right, that one has
another type of analysis and
statistical calculation in which we correlate
point by point each of the samples
for us to see here with it here the
correlation coefficient is zero 98
because it means here of course that here is
missing the guy that there will be a limit against
viral load om2000ec the line here its
correlation with  the perfect one she is 45 and she
is just lying right in the middle
which is very similar to this line that
we can see here and here is
another type of analysis when we
try to see if there is any
viral load value where the correlation  higher
or lower and we can clearly see here
that the samples with lower viral loads,
we have a suspension order in
this graph, indicating that
there is a slightly lower ratio
in the motorcycle to be lower degree than is
fully expected open to the motorcycle to
put grids  bigger is the
closer to the ticket, right, it has to be in
an hour it's oscillation of the
quantification itself both one and the
other and in the same equipment
only we wake up all the same
on the bike at limit n or again
1000 2000 us  see a graph very
similar to this one here
is more open said that we call
this trend this deviation that we
called bays here after zero eleven
so how to dis  if the pattern of 0 29
then we also see it and this is the
most important part for the growth of
this type of analysis that one shows the
same love you coded between the two
platforms on average it will differ
zero eleven the aline will give a result 0.11
higher than the m2000 i.e. I
don't need to kiss your
patient that I've been following for
m2000 I can continue following for the
limit because the
highly correlated methodologies are very similar so
there's no need for any type of
adjustment and correction at all  that
the two methodologies practically behave the same way
and the next audio which was the
environment for the hepatitis virus to be we
also work with the panel
provided by the company harald here is the
panel of three hcb genotypes one by one
kiss three  most frequent subjects in
brazil are most frequent in the
united states also throughout western europe
also in three levels of concentration 10
25 and 10 unit  s internationals per ml and
again 15 aliquots I ask we
did 135 there when stressed and 5
days at 27 per day right so there were five
days of testing these three aliquots from
three books of concentration of these
balls what are the results similar
to the theme  it was for you to get hiv already at the
level of 100 international units per
ml we have here even the genotype aa
how much for a b I count three a
very small deviations right and here are the
standard deviations and gives the coefficient of variation a
little higher by pulling o  it was three but
again also intervals that do not
interfere with any
clinical decision and here also the same
results already with a much
lower level idh cd here I am showing 25
international units per ml we
must averages are not very similar
both of us  two viral load values
also
in relation to the detection rate all
samples in the panel were detected by
the line system to have a
detection rate and without  percent and in relation
to Dutch reproducibility for the
controls, we also had the averages
very close to the values ​​postulated in the
package insert for the controls in terms of
strong positive with one million copies per
international unit per ml against
weak positive is close to military per
ml values  it's a little less than a thousand
here because a thousand would be three or an idea,
right, and it's difficult to have a very low pattern
within our 0902018 when you activate it in
action here between one and three percent is
very low too so it's very
reproducible the system
is about  we went to the
correlation study here the bike was also analyzed
199 so repeating right these
samples were run 2000/2000 in the
routine and then run 20 30 money
so it's worth 30 days in aline tiemi
the same tubes don't measure the same
highly  the same motorcycle and here we
received even greater general agreement,
which was hiv-1 of 96 and a half
percent we only have 27 the motorcycle
hides they are  are marked in bold
there four of them had a very
low reflection value than in the year 2000 and
were not detected by alinity one
sample which was that there is no
higher classification by he two thousand and lower
by there is limit and one two samples that
there were lower values ​​for the 2 thousand
he sleeps higher for the there is limit
making then this degree of agreement
of 96 and a half
hi hi as you can see here the vast
majority of the samples were totally
concurrent and then how do we go
to the graph  of correlation,
then we always see a little bit there, almost the same as
for hiv, but without that trend when
we had seen the lower samples in
that neighborhood.
people detect more eating the
same average of 0.16 also last the
third the viral load test that we
analyzed was viral load day to
see you for that we also have the
prepared panel three weighted te with two
genotypes only type ar and genotypes and
in brazil márcio valiant is ar followed
by de then is not in how we
used exactly the distribution of
ice
how do we check in brazil there are
three books of  concentration 2100/10 the
international data per ml and also
here we did a total of 90
aliquots were taken care of there control of
each one of them here tested in 5 days
and the results here look we can see
with two thousand international units per
ml both genotype  the phenotype you very
similar to the average of the values ​​obtained and
the deviations very low as you can
see here both for 2000 count for 100
international units per ml increase
a little say if it approaches intercede
per cent still considered the
result quite accurate and the
qualitative language  for detection of ninety
-three percent just one of the techniques
of the erotic you
and it is with concentration there of 10 thousand
apologies of 100 units  international units
per ml was not detected
at rua hunter an overall detection rate
of ninety-three
percent just go back a little bit here
the condition of the panel this is right or not
table no 10
international units here on this one on this
slide here we  we are talking about 10
international units per ml and we
lost only one motorbike it was not detected
here giving a total of ninety-three
percent of sensitivity here we
can see the reproducibility of the
controls which is always very high right in
all the compositions detected inside
Of the very large ones, these values
that were expected with Jesus very low,
and finally, a test of what
relationship when we equal the
correlation of 94%, we will look at
the correlation graph, we see it here
too, but different from the others.  that
I tend to a
subclassification by the east in the range
of 01 and I still considered it quite low
and the correlation value is the highest
of the  three at
and analyzing in conclusion the summary of the
performance of the qualitative hiv hcv hbv tests
is that he learned the
performance specifications that are
described in the sections of use so what
was written on the leaflet how do we
check in block right when we are
there  in terms of species, the total neighborhood
observed did not receive clinically
significant for you,
so here it is considered a
bad smooth transition since patients
can be followed without following
a methodology, they can migrate to another
without major consequences
o e 87.6 per  percent in the
quantifiable results patient difference
less than 69 hiv in 98 and one hundred percent a
difference less than a log hc v&h baby
so the results very similar very similar
devices like you to you
and the other proof that we looked at is that
chrome is very important how  I said it
was there at the beginning there are tests for
sexually transmitted
infections run sexually
transmitted infections  levels are contained in
the alinne thiele family test for tomato not
serious when it falls has like us vaginali
he bought some irritable
and then they also went fishing in the form of
a panel it had these four
sexually transmitted infectious agents
and a fifth a fifth
preparation that has the  four all
together and you will see why
we also analyzed it all with
low concentration twice the
detection limit and each one of them then very
close to the detection limit
we need your aliquot of 5 goes right
because 30 in 2 days here  I already showed you the
result so, for example, the
suzuki family motorcycle dashboard has
been made and all the replicas were
positive and because it is a
qualitative analysis, we do not have
load concentration values, but
we have to have  as a marker
running alongside the number of people
present at the show, it is not even that intention to
whom the intention was to show that the
world panel q  what will happen to the media or
circus panel that has clarity in the same
concentration in the presence of the other three
agents they gave practically
identical certainty what does this mean
you mean that the presence of other
microorganisms does not influence the
result of family health no
the difference between analysts here is very
positive since they want the same
frequency there we find two or three
sometimes concomitant in the sample is female
or male and the same serious thing
happened to bother you claudinalle
and the same happened for mycoplasma
genitalium that
hi  and then we set off to work seriously
then send that panel workout
with a lot just now there's that
compilation test when we take the
routine samples from the laboratory and
also that we are in the
laboratory we calmly use the serious law
also the platform it 2000 da  art and
to annoy you and mycoplasma
genitalium I had to use the
multiplex d test  the furniture company with which is
a multiprice part there that includes
others we also not only
looked at mycoplasma
the type of sample here was used the
famous and gynecological here the urine fee is
quite frequent in the
diagnoses of chlamydia and also love
that I gynecological and  these samples
were collected both in the
collection bottle and it already comes with the
sexually transmitted kit that I
called multi-collect or the common
commonly used means of
liquid cytology in the case here we work
as it increases if it is the brand's presence
on the site  You know, it's in the woods of logic to
get plasma balls used so
only Tio Pepe so you work
colorful mayor type of sample
what you can enter comparison of
results separated by agent 117 19
samples were submitted to
concomitant tests for chlamydia and  neither serious and
here are the positive emotions for both
tests here are were positive the
reference test in the c  aso here is the one
of two thousand and negative for the environment
then four for chlamydia and misery and the
only one shows that it was positive for
half serious in there elite negative same
is and this part here of the negative
working too we have time  a
positive correlation of ninety-five
percent negative correlation of 99
percent a compilation generally
97/98 percent between the test of the there is a
limit of sexually
transmitted infections and the comparative test
as I said with the media in the sphere
9000/2000 and for  it was good in that
coplas in that multiplex I commented with
you and here for it's good that I
gynecological basically we have
very similar results also giving
a general agreement of 98 and a half percent
in summary the performance of the test limit
it for sexually
transmitted infection is that no  it opens
interference if you have the presence
of more than one agency from that of the
concomitant panel on the bike since there is no
variation of  o ct for as o without those
that make up the other microorganism
all panel members were
detected correctly identified and
assay performance against
sample type both urine versus vaccine
ecological was of excellent agreement
and methods above 97 percent
hi and the last test i wanted to talk
to you about was milk valley it for
high risk hpv this is the test that has a design that has
already evolved in relation to
the 2000/2000 design why why ol2000
for those who already use weigh those who do not
it is an assay that detects 14
high-risk hpv genotypes,
hpv16 being identified in isolation hpv-18
identified in isolation and the other
twelve genotypes a large group is
called other high-risk hpv there is no
limit no passage has been expanded
detailed so if  I have I have 16
detect individually or 18 detected
individually the 45 detected
visually and then two cocktails
called high risk is also not
ch  beloved high risk there I others high
risk a and others high risk b
this is the expanded genotyping profile
and what is the importance of this the
importance of what are placed more or less
is the more or less they are not placed
here in the oncological risk order of
transforming capacity of each
hpv you know 16 then but not with genic
league 2018 then the 45 after this
group here are already high risk hpv but
with less homogeneous propensity and
lastly this group here of one two three
four five six seven hpv that  it has less
oncogenic potential, although it is with
high-risk schools because this
also allows individualized management
of the risk of each patient
personally.
replacing the
pap smear test so it allows you to have
different conducts and algorithms a
patient has hpv
to do just for example there is this
high risk group  co called b
well so here in the inside the
correlation we are 218 the bike how
are you having lunch here in this table and
you can see here the results a 49
were detected on both platforms
m2000 buy aline here and we had
very little different results  one
thing that I think you should pay attention to
is that what we see is
that most of the positive moto
has a group of hpv if it's neither 16 nor
18 nor 45 because it's in here
then  it makes sense we will be able to
handle it differently this is only
possible to be known and
tested differently hence the interest in people
have a test with more details from the point
of view of the patient's diagnostic profile
and something I want to call
attention that we had 22 the bike were
positive
for hpv high risk others no 16 no 18 in
the brazil test
good so they were detected by aline there
are 22 the bike later I will show
you so you always look here  in
detail what we did here not
only did we get an hpv result that
reminded me of me but also in relation
because given that we do a lot this is not
psychological in parallel to the
positive hpv molecular test the two
results and that we can see  here
and here the first one that 22 here is the
download movie is the the classification
presiding cytological normal then
we have before gradations here are the
technologies altered meaning
undetermined cytology altered from
which
high-risk lesions to low-grade lesions cannot be excluded
high-grade injury then transfer
classifications from the left presents from
normal to the most effective operations
from the most severe and the 22 cases and on that
previous slide you for you
here what were these here that
high-risk hpv were detected others and
that aline did not  detector this bike are
here
the poets 22 as you can see
they all have normal cytology
insect meaning osteology in  in general these are
alterations that have no correlation with
the natural onset of cervical trial leprosis.
This means this means
that there was a modification of the katoff of
the limit itself so that the
results would have greater clinical significance
when you use the screening that
is to say us  you don't want to detect hpv in
patients who don't have anything they don't want
technology than normal psychology
so we have to pay to
see that it has clinical significance and that's
what's important here as you can
see these 24 samples that had the te
grab l silva and hc cytology option
changed to be valued all of them
were hpv positive so
and the summary of unemployment and the year and m
do learn high risk is that it was
presented accuracy when compared to the
purchase the result of enem 2017
hpv percent 16 and 18  you saw that
evaluation was only for the other types
no 16 no 18 and all the samples with
your cell phone I put altered that is
valued possible  want to have
something to be detected and all samples
can learn not detected by aline
were cytology or normal or just
those 32 22
and finally we want to evaluate the
response time of the equipment what does
that mean is to see in the real world there
inside the laboratory how long it
would take to do each one of the
analyzes there were placed
individual analyzes like real equipment train
with ordinance from the point of view
not of the precision of the result that has already been
evaluated in the reproducibility of the
result for you for you but
basically it comes back to other variables  are
equally important in the
high productivity laboratory as this laboratory
that we have there so we
evaluated we set the various
start times for the motorcycle to enter the
laboratory the time the sample entered at
that moment the time the motorcycle was
released  the result is a tran instrument
hi people if you want to be able to
visualize something to  we have
Tati, you know, I have the total time from the time the
bike arrived at the lab until the
time the result is released, in
this case, we have the time the girl is on board,
that is, it has to be placed in the
instrument and the  result
it is the third time that the
processing time he said four hours
that she has lunch began to be processed until
the time she has minutes processed the
result released these times are
different because the first thing the
lack of her arriving at the laboratory never
say that  she told me the process the fact that
it was placed in the equipment
does not mean that it also started to be
processed so they are different times
what we got here from question
time two and time
31 what we work on basically is
time three ok me  time between the bike you
put in the equipment this is aspirated
medicine and it starts to work
so we worked with real samples that
I received from the normal sample flow  going
to the laboratory it goes through
the pre-analytical procedures and then it
enters our automation room where we
have there yes mainly you me 2007
luxscan your grandma got it and we
don't need flow with the same samples
so we put the same
barcode she had here here  instead of using
real motorcycles the same people used the motorcycle with
water and this was done in parallel at
exactly the same time the motorcycle followed
its process here with all the measures
that we mentioned and here the sample with
water is prepared the same process being
processed in the  livia
and we used love you ask for
this one for this study very similar
to a laboratory routine
anytime i call we
used thirty percent of the famous ones i
know the study was r&b viral load
if we know that in our continue
in october twenty-eight percent
of the samples were submitted to viral load you
will see very similar to the
routine in the laboratory to start the process well
real time is the real world and said 1068
sample and for participated in this
study here we can see so I
put the eyelashes here first
hiv viral load lol cv50 big load to
see you 435 was that it was sexually
transmitted and 163 is hpv and
and o  result there is no limit it has
percent of the samples were processed
within two hours what does that mean
when you know here at the moment that
sample was aspirated by the equipment
feed the result allowed within
two hours without percent of the samples
and here it is independent  of the tests
we are a very easy type to visualize
here but regardless of any of the
tests the processing time was in the
range of 2 hours
hi and it
is right here super important people
put in comparison here you
answer left in two months here on the
right o  aline tiemi when we
had then no percent of the bike I'm
alone until 2:00 but when we look at
the total processing time it's not
from mom  so that it was put on the
equipment and not at the moment transpired
that all put the equipment until the
mission of the result 30 and ninety-five
percent of the feet completed in up to 5
hours he buys that he 2095 percent
of the 10 completed and until 7:30 then
equipment more  fast and basically
this is the difference between the moment it
starts and the time we know it
takes with it two thousand is to process a
96 plate around 7:30 7:30 that
we had this difference the one that
these two  results
and we also used the so-
called status of the urgent samples system
and if it is worth it of course that there is the
possibility of canonical access then
an urgent motorcycle entered the laboratory and
it was immediately loaded there is no
limit in the m2100 to arrive a motorcycle from it
be marked as urgent it  it will enter
the first routine that is processed
so when we compared it, it
is this little red one that you are seeing
here, it is difficult to visualize but there
were 20  samples so in five
different essays were portrayed how did
you get urgency and here again
not him 2000 the fastest it came out was
in seven hours and a little 7:15 then 7:30
versus aline tiemi we didn't have there without
percent of lunch status of the  our
way in up to 4 hours which of course not
bad people makes a lot of difference
hi guys compare the total response time
between the aline that is in blue and the
grammy 2010 which is five years
equipment it 26 which is the laboratory
we see this  difference so without
percent of the samples
the duality had their results
reported in up to nine hours versus here
the bike without percent of the famous ones that
were posted in two days had
results reported in up to 84 hours
so here we are talking about the
real world with motorcycles were  being placed from the
m2000 as the laboratory works
with me two months using using one
application for another and these
results have finished being processed
released and seven  ta and four hours after
the motorcycle arrives in the sector it's not that over
there where there are percent
results as responsible and up to 9
hours to get on the motorcycle bless
me to see that I'm not saying that aline
professor the thousand samples in 9 hours  that's not
it here all the samples had
their result cut and even barely it's
arrived in the
sector your present when we compare the
processing time for your friend and
neither serious and hpv and they are critical cases
because because in the laboratory we use
the  same sample to make planet in
sphere and hpv and it is not uncommon for the
prescriber to ask for both f when he
asks for both samples first but I will
give another shape until the end and then it
will be placed on the other platform that
you are seeing here only the  same the bike
it was shot here not the first bet
here are 64 samples were shot here
for your life I will seriously go to the emmy 2010
then they went to do the hpv so the
singer from here the first one leaves with 36 hours
without entering  from the motorcycle in the laboratory
and now if you could here this other group
here look he was in a second in the
second sample group already later
me even when we compare to who
we see the result of from there tm64 the
motorcycle were all released in  up to nine
o'clock is the entry into the laboratory in the motorcycle
so a
very large difference in processing time and I
don't remember yet we are comparing the
equipment against five different pieces of equipment
so
and mainly a girl who is
blocked there that she cut her
work here that I  I'm primary that the
average time is 30 hours for the second
result so it came out first with life
not even serious and then again 30 hours
to have the hpv result, but I
already told you, aline had until
9:00 then  from the point of view of the
workflow what we consider
operational impact the
consistently fast processing time i.e. slack the
bike sweaty that result will
come out in  two hours
and it works very well attention to
update urgent motorbikes which is a great thing right
advantages laboratory that attends to
emergencies our case we are inside
hospitals and gives it to us sometimes it is
important that it is an urgent motorbike this
result comes out in up to 4 hours and the space
nec ó consider unlimited m occupied the
space much smaller than 5
cv2000 system the question of random access to the
great characteristics most advantageous
of the equipment so the alien that I
'm without percent of the results on the day
of the arrival of the bike
I'm sorry compared to several
five days needed m2000 systems
the cattle mainly the question of the
need to analyze in shows is not
every time you have and 96 of
that analyst's bike to test then you
wait to complete the batch this does not exist
in aline fm and the flexibility right
any test can  be done at
any time again I have no foot
I'll put the samples but that
we are already slowly it will
running running running
this gives a lot of flexibility that the
laboratory also so very big
difference that we consider the fact of
working with everything the only pay to
live and sexually
transmitted infections and quickly a great
advantage because because our public
we have  a lot of tests with you for you to
be hpv family and many times the request
is hpv and family
and in addition our orientation is to
work together with the
molecular biology sector in the
pathological anatomy sector in the sense that
the cytology operator already has  the
hpv result that he goes to luana there
it improves the quality of the
reading a lot for that we cannot
delay the release of the result so
the time here ends up being a very
important time laboratory that does 30 40
thousand cervico-vaginal cytology more per
means also then the need not
having the need to separate the
essays to separate by essay optimism of
work and  it decreases the total
processing time a big difference
quite big in addition to that one of the
employees who operate one there is a limit is
much smaller than the number of
employees operate five it two
months last
to thank you do not have to know you
position questions and leaving the  take
e-mail for any further contact
thank you very
much loading from the americas
informative presentation let's start the
question and answer part now no if you
have any questions please ask them
now just apply in the home this
conversation located on the
left end of the screen we will respond to  cover
ask how many when you have time
we will comment on our first
question in your opinion what is your
main benefit what are the
laboratories changing their cleaning is
and look to give the main the two
main benefits are the great
efficiency and what I am referring to for
example  this question of samples in the
question of time also because we have
a p  quite large resion per
time once we attend the laboratory it's
already been where the bike I've been coming from
somewhere I've been just
waiting for the transport time because it's
easy for us we have centralized so the
operating time and I have random access
that  it also relates to time, right
because it allows how can i
process it to continue mind at 10 and
wait for betty to form and
we have to be a second question which
is where species during its presentation
is right very right for
sexually transmitted infections like  you see
the clinical and operational usefulness of
processing these four markers at the
same time this is a very
good question and this is one of the great advantages
that we come a lot we were
very happy that it already exists it happens
on the aline platform, right because it is  common
record holder in general urologist request
at least two agents these four
are the
most common sexually transmitted infections together  I go to
the hpv right so it's quite common for some
hpv request and the other is your friend
for example hpv family learn with
a sincere mind any request like that and
the fact that we use a girl from just me and
the
test is a big advantage  in addition, the
system allows us to mark, that is,
following which the prescriber can ask for
chlamydia and hpv let's just talk about the
304 surprise album test that was
asked with a friend I came back the result of the
law seriously I'm going to have the mycoplasma result I'm
going to have  the result of
bothering you but the scheme will not release
these results no one will
know which result was the
correct one since we only cut
what was requested this
possibility of mask at the same time
up to 14 days the doctor has it for you  it
will not add the second to the result and this
result will be available in the system
I will not need protection for the bike
just put it in the order that took the
exam the result will
be ready now  waiting to be released and
also
and let's start a question whether
you always do you see it's burning
pity if it's very different from what you
currently use how do you see the ease
and response of the electrical groups that
you serve, right
and look, this is it  I
think I spoke in the presentation about
this very strongly, but the possibility of you
almost classifying the patient according to
the risk for cancer, right, this type of
function of the hpv test, it goes hand in hand
with the evolution of the location of the hpv test
in the management of the patient, you know, they did
the test that was and still is in Brazil
very much used to
diagnose a patient who has a lesion or
cytological alteration but the whole world
is positioned the test as a screening
so it changes roles with cytology
in  in this sense, at the time of the
screening, you can know which hpv is, is it
that we are talking about knowing that it
is in the vaccine it is not in the vaccine it has
important implications  regarding the
management the preached in countries that have already
implemented screening based on hpv the
behavior with different patience
a 16 verse if she has another hpv like
this group there the groups a and b that was
placed here in the new test of aline
tiemi so he gives a  a
much greater flexibility and customization of
the patient's result at the end this will
incur system savings and less
stress also for patients who
are not infected by hpv 16 or 18 for
example allows for more
conservative management from now on I understand
that this  It will require medical education
, which is also important. Your message
is not yet ubiquitous in
Brazil, but it will bring the best
quality to a list of patients and
therefore I think it will please doctors and
patients for sure.
we're going to have to wrap up here, but one
day I'd like to ask if
you have any final comments for
our audience
and we don't  no it's good no i just wanted to
thank you again for the opportunity you're talking
to the public it's the brazilians who are
watching present making me
available is talking about shoelaces you're always
available also to exchange ideas
exchange information and that ours
will soon have an experience
Greater use of this equipment in
our routine
thank you very much again that I lost
everything I feel today was important
research We would also like to thank
the side to see and so there are those used
as a sponsor port subscribe to the
channel today before  irmos would like to
thank you for your escape and met us today
your interesting
questions the unanswered questions and those
created during beings where masters will be
answered by the speakers in
the data and contact medium if you are call me
at the time of
registration facebook can know about demand  until
the other 2025 the russian side and salon
prima eu when available to
rep  oduction we encourage you to
share with your colleagues if they may
have missed today's live huh
thank you and until next time